if you've been waiting for a kitchen reveal
this isn't it
I'm sorry
but I do owe you a kitchen update and I need your help
so stick around till the end
so this is where we started before we started pulling it apart
if you want the full back story
I'll link the video in the caption below but essentially
we're just giving this kitchen a wee facelift
the old bench got removed
which I think my American friends called countertops?
whatever you call them we didn't have them for two weeks
which was a bit of a punish
but two weeks came and went and
In and went the new stone and the new sink
which if you know me you know I'm very excited about
In went the tap
and I spent a good amount of time playing with my new hose
hubby cut some drywall
which we call GIB ready for the new tile and as of this moment right now
this is where we're at
I need to paint literally everything
including the door
which I painted the wrong shade of green ages ago and just never corrected
and I mentioned in the previous video
I was gonna show you how the sensor works on the new tap
so there you go this is how it works
I think it's pretty bloody cool actually
I'm gonna put some cute brass handles everywhere
and obviously we need to tile
and this is where you come in
I've narrowed it down to 3 options
but I keep changing my mind
cause a big part of me really does a clean white on white kitchen
but then colour is so fun
but also scary
so I don't know, what would you choose?
and I will give you the full rundown on the stone
but that deserves its own video